je m'appelle Minnie au Pérou, je suis infirmière
au centre de santé des inlets en Vénétie.
Je travaille ici depuis aussi longtemps que
je suis infirmière. J'ai grandi à Greg bien,
également connu sous le nom de cuisinier.
59 ans vieux ce qui t'a
décidé à aller à l'école pour devenir
infirmière euh c'est une histoire étrange et longue et
qu'il y avait une infirmière qui venait de
Grande-Bretagne en Angleterre son nom était
Miss Murray dernièrement et elle était là pour
probablement 20 ans et nous nous sommes rapprochés et
quand le gouvernement fédéral a commencé à
envoyer des étudiants à Churchill au Manitoba,
elle voulait que j'y aille, alors elle a obtenu le
ministre anglican derrière elle parce que mes
parents ne voulaient pas me laisser partir, elle a
finalement dit que je paierai  vous vingt-cinq
dollars par mois pour me laisser aller à
churchill et ma mère m'a laissé partir pour
vingt-cinq dollars
que
pour moi alors euh j'ai quitté une école d'infirmières
quand j'avais o  Il ne restait plus que six mois et je
n'en ai pas guéri pendant 20 ans et j'y
suis retourné après 20 ans
qu'est-ce que c'était au sujet des soins infirmiers qui
vous a attiré à un si jeune âge J'aide à
aider les miens Mlle Lachlan
m'a fait commencer fait  la volonté commencera à se
déplacer là-bas je l'ai vue aider beaucoup
de gens et cela m'a vraiment attiré
comme elle a aidé ma mère parce que ma
mère ne pourrait jamais avoir d'enfants qui sont
restés en vie j'ai trois frères et
trois sœurs et ils sont tous morts et j'ai
vu le  l'infirmière l'aidait vraiment y avait-
il d'autres infirmières des infirmières inuites dans votre
communauté quand vous grandissiez
non personne avec n'importe quelle
profession avez-vous parlé de cela quand
vous êtes allé à l'école d'infirmières que les
blancs n'étaient pas prêts pour vous alors
était-ce une mauvaise expérience à ce moment-là euh
vous ne savez pas à quel point et probablement
personne ne saura jamais comment  b  et
c'est ce qui vous a finalement fait revenir en
arrière et terminer vos études
et devenir elle il y a 16 ans
nous vivions à Yellowknife il n'y a
pas d'écoles d'infirmières là-bas et quand nous avons
déménagé à Timmins j'ai réalisé qu'il y avait une
école d'infirmières  là-bas et j'ai continué à postuler
pour RN et ils ont continué à me rejeter mais j'ai
continué à postuler chaque automne en septembre
finalement quand j'ai postulé pour RNA, ils
m'ont accueilli et j'ai transféré
plus tard dans la classe d'infirmière autorisée quelle était
l'expérience de l'école d'infirmières pour vous
comme la deuxième fois  à peu près
la même chose à peu près la même chose mais cette fois
j'étais beaucoup plus adulte beaucoup plus mature
et plus dur dans mon cœur, donc tu
as pu traverser tout ce que je pense que j'étais
en classe quand nous avons obtenu notre diplôme je
pensais à mon autre ancienne classe
en pensant qu'est-ce qu'ils diraient qu'ils m'ont vu
maintenant une fois que vous avez commencé à voir des patients
quelle a été la réaction de la communauté
préventive à l'égard des Inuits
quelle a été la réaction quand vous êtes
entré  une chambre d'accord euh le premier
des premiers patients que j'ai eu il était en
fauteuil roulant et je suis entré avec ma petite
tasse pleine de médicaments et il
me regardait comme pourquoi tu me donnes des
médicaments et nous ne me donnons pas de
médicaments  l'autre ringard les infirmières
me donnent des médicaments alors je lui ai expliqué que
je suis une infirmière et puis il a écouté pendant un
moment ce que je disais sur la façon dont je suis une
infirmière alors et sans rien dire de
plus il était vraiment parti comme si nous étions en
charge  ici quelle est la réaction comme
maintenant quand vous entrez dans une pièce j'espère
qu'ils sont fiers il a fallu beaucoup de temps pour s'y
habituer il m'a fallu beaucoup de temps pour
m'y habituer et pour eux de s'y
habituer  moi quels sont selon vous les principaux
défis de la prestation de soins de santé dans
le nord ce sont les grandes distances et
le roulement est vraiment incroyable le
roulement est incroyable nous sommes loin
d'un endroit quelque part les gens
perçoivent comme important et ici au Québec ses
langues d'accord  tout le monde ne parle pas
le s  même langue, donc certains des
messages sont vraiment tordus et cela peut avoir un
impact sur la santé des personnes qui sont
les consommateurs de soins de santé défis
également liés au mensonge
qui lorsque je traduis tout le
matériel pédagogique et il est très difficile de
traduire la terminologie médicale  dans une
bande de nerds, l'autre défi était que
parce que le dans lequel ils voient du
maquereau pas Michael, ils ne comprennent pas les
germes ou ils ne
comprennent pas que votre sang circule dans
votre corps, il est difficile de leur expliquer
qu'il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas avec leur
corps avec comme le diabète et quand ils
ne se sentent pas malades quand quelqu'un tombe malade
dans la cellule, ils font des analyses de sang pour voir
ce qui ne va pas avec vous et ils font une
interview sur vous et quand vous faites
ça sur n'importe quelle personne qu'ils font '
Je ne comprends pas nécessairement pourquoi vous faites qu'ils ne comprennent pas nécessairement
ce que vous interviewez ils disent
certains certains d'entre eux je pense que je pense juste
que vous leur rendez visite donc
c'est difficile
sont  les problèmes de santé que les gens
vous apportent sont-ils différents maintenant
qu'ils ne l'étaient que lorsque vous avez commencé de mon
point de vue euh lié au diabète
il y a des bébés obésité il a augmenté il n'y a
pas de manque de nourriture maintenant les gens ne savent pas
quels aliments sont de bons choix  pourquoi les gens
ont des horaires de repas mon petit-
déjeuner, mon déjeuner et mon dîner et nous n'avons pas ce
jour-là quand et quand il y a de la nourriture
disponible et cela affecte-t-il la santé
même maintenant, c'est surtout pour la personne
qui est pré-diabétique et dont le corps a du
mal à  contrôler leur glycémie
et oui, nous avons beaucoup entendu dans
les autres régions de l'Arctique également que
les systèmes de santé sont basés sur la
façon de faire des cali du sud et ne
tiennent pas compte de la culture inuite et je suis
curieux de savoir si vous  'ai vu cela soit en tant qu'infirmière, soit en tant que
personne vivant et travaillant dans
le nord, c'est très frustrant des deux
côtés car les infirmières s'attendent à
ce que la réaction soit la même que dans le
sud et ce n'est pas l'infirmière g  ets
frustré parce que parfois l'Inuit
ne suit pas les instructions de l'infirmière
car peut-être qu'il n'a pas compris peut-être que
sa culture ne le fait pas ou non
ce n'est pas une chose normale de faire un indien
avec de la culture mais l'infirmière veut qu'ils le
fassent  pour qu'ils puissent être à nouveau en bonne santé, mais
ils travaillent les uns contre les autres, il
doit y avoir un chemin vers le sud avant de
les
embaucher, il doit y avoir une
orientation culturelle et il doit y avoir
quelqu'un là-bas qui dit que c'est ce que
tu vas  rencontrer ce sont les
gens et cela vient de quelqu'un qui
sait de quoi ils parlent Joe
Carroll Carroll que pensez-vous qu'il
faut faire pour avoir plus d'infirmières
de la communauté travaille dans le
nord des gens comme vous essayant d'obtenir le
histoire que nous avons besoin d'eux, d'enseignants et de
personnes en charge de l'éducation
qui poussent vraiment en poussant en poussant
c'est une très bonne expérience d'être
infirmière, vous obtenez plus que vous ne donnez et
vous sauvez des vies, donc c'est v  C'est
quand tu vois une personne s'améliorer c'est
pourquoi tu es devenu infirmier quand tu la vois se
faire mordre te considères-tu comme un
modèle non et je ne veux pas être vraiment j'ai l'
impression de savoir te qualifier